[Music]
watch TV today at your consoles can I
ask you a question of course
go ahead
his home
[Music]
wanna come on let's go
come on June
[Music]
almost at the new house guys
come on girls turn that one goes with me
into the kitchen hana take that upstairs
into your room
[Music]
um what are you doing I want to see
what's up there pass me that box no way
smells like old people up here Carly
wants such a fan of dead body in Natick
really that's what she told me
[Music]
what's that
so it says here that these are
frequencies it also says here it's
illegal to operate a ham radio without
license I saw that written in here
hello
[Music]
are you okay it'll probably work better
outside
[Music]
November alpha one Sears here November
alpha one Sears here
hello
[Music]
Hana are you all ready to go hurry up
we're gonna be late
we have to get rid of these luncheons
it's not horrible to other people but
I'm hungry let's go sir with those girls
I don't know come on it's not a big deal
you go ahead fine wish me luck
[Music]
okay today yeah I think he's awake
right there yeah I didn't even notice so
that girl Christine read me over do you
want to come maybe next time okay well
how long would be home before dinner
here how she gets
[Music]
Hey what are you doing with my truck
hey you alright
why are you sitting out here with the
trash
no reason well you hungry Carl how many
times do I have to tell you you can't
keep their dentures on the table it's
only food it's common sense
pretty exciting stuff ain't it I still
remember when they lost a monkey into
space 1948 he was catapulted into that
black abyss that floats over us and he
never came back
here none don't forget to take these but
in that moment the little chimp became a
space pioneer for future monkeys like us
ignoring Herod pancakes with a secret
prolong life
my mom says ginseng is sometimes
delicious pancakes
she says he cures everything from colds
to hurry
what's that
oh it's just the soldiery here I found
I haven't seen this mommy for ages know
about these things
I'm old of course I know about these
things
oh and there's a snow book with all
these coats in it there's this one I
heard on the radio November 1 zero
Sierra yeah how did you know well you
were talking to that black abyss that
the monkey had led us to
space
space I'm not sure if this is working
[Music]
what Sears here do you copy
Daniel looks like Jack he's blond and
yes I think he has blue eyes but he's
cuter and they're brothers
maybe we calculate the time of day wrong
what is she doing now
[Music]
I'm not actually sure November alpha one
Sears year she made contact that
pictures are awesome send it to me okay
[Music]
Johanna you and where were you Oh
putting me out with whom it's Friday
night
were you smoking no you reek of
cigarettes
Oh dinner's ready
[Music]
oh there so I have this new antenna
design we can try that was the Dayton
ham vention 1997 that was a good year
I've been thinking and you should have
this well I have one already I'll just
leave it here then I'm becoming the
weird kid at school you know who is
weird
Einstein was weird Picasso Mozart a
bunch of weirdos you know you remind me
a lot of my daughter when she was your
age
you may not see it now but one day when
you look back you'll be grateful for
being weird let's try this new antenna
so if I go to a more open clearing I can
get a better connection exactly the
trees and buildings around here are
obstructing the signal as the
International Space Station passes by
there's only a short window of time to
make the connection 7:03 p.m. pointing
upward falling and northeastern that
there
let me try it why are you hitting it
like that back in the day when our
electronics malfunction we give him a
good old-fashioned whack
[Music]
what would you ask the astronauts on the
ISS I think I'd ask him how it looks
from out there
in the great framework of things a life
is only a fraction of a second in a
universe that's almost 14 billion years
old I'd like to hear from someone
outside of everything someone who
understands what really matters
[Music]
hi Katie
I'm Lily nice to meet you yeah I've left
a list of phone numbers and emergency
contacts beside the TV and here is money
for pizza tonight my keys let me guess
you must be Jim Ohana darn well I had
50% chance June is working on a science
project until about 5:00 tonight call me
if you need anything
Hana I'm working a double tonight on the
base I'll be home in the morning you
girls be good all right I wonder how
many animals died to make this coat oh
my goodness picture - all right let me
see how it looks okay
hashtag hot stuff yeah I know Irish my
mom would let me get a cell phone
yeah my mom's all right like that but
she checks it like every day so I have
to delete everything you don't have a
phone no does
karna would love this oh my gosh look
exactly like your sister I would put
that down
what do you think super cute I would get
it it's $18 you can't afford that
what are you doing what it's no big deal
it's just a shirt besides I can totally
outrun that guy it's not a big deal we
do it all the time you know there are
security cameras everywhere right
[Music]
oh hey you must be June
yeah I'm Katie your babysitter Honus
upstairs if you wanted to know
[Music]
Albert do you copy
it's Hana over now
June
[Music]
why don't you get a hair do I found one
out of thrift store it was supposed to
be for you where are you anyway I'm
trying to get a better signal so I'm
going to the top of the mountain
why there's just someone I really have
to talk to you
[Music]
how can I help
yeah there should be a hiking path that
starts there
[Music]
Hana did you hear how loud that thunder
was I mean where's Hana she's not
feeling well she's been in the bathroom
for a while all right
I haven't seen it for a little bit so
got a little worried hello
yeah no no
um
Hana are you there all right jigs up I
know one of you isn't here she's in the
basement I'm calling it
on
Albert
you
[Music]
when I was gonna kill me
June where's your sister
[Music]
really June why up the mountain
she wants got a better connection to
talk to the three station why the Space
Station turn left up here
[Music]
Albert
are you alright but I'm alright don't a
frequency 144 0.49 Jun do you copy
Hana I'm here I wanna grounded for the
rest of the year
I know mom I gotta go
November alpha one Sierra Sierra do copy
November alpha one Sierra Sierra do you
copy
November alpha one Sears here do you
this is November alpha one Sierra Sierra
I hear you loud and clear for the
International Space Station over hi this
is Hannes song can I ask you a question
of course
go ahead what does the air should look
like from way up there it's bright
colorful
[Music]
it looks like home
do you ever miss home I do I think about
it a lot again I really struggled to
find where I fit in around I feel like
that sometimes too
[Music]
I just had to change my perspective
and now whenever I think of the word
home I don't think of a place
I think of my family
my sister
it took me years to realize that I could
change over time
but it isn't a destination
or a location
and once you find that place
anywhere you make it
now that you know how their story begins
join Hannah and June on their historic
mission to make Mars home
we're looking at a red planet we the
greatest adventure ever Mars a global
event series Mondays at 9:00
starting November 14th on National
Geographic
[Music]
you